on the bound for the san diego padres
is chris paddy 25 year old make his 14th
start still looking for his first
victory
against the diamondbacks this year he's
won each of his last two starts
good outings against the mets and the
reds the strikeouts are very apparent
nine against
the mets 11 against the reds
goes down and gets it lines it off the
glove of hosmer at first cronenworth has
no play and rojas
boy he earned that base hit rocket down
the line
right at hosmer hosmer right off the tip
of his glove
swinging a man celebrates and escobar
strikes out first k of the night for
chris paddock
first and second right now for arizona
with rojas at second peralta at first
30th pitch of the inning coming here for
paddock
a 1-2 drops in there for strike three
second strike out of the inning
diamondback strand to pair podrager
coming up
starter tonight corbin martin his third
start this year mixed results and a
couple of long relief outings since his
last start back on may 25th
tommy fam leading it off fam drives one
to deep right field rojas going back at
the whoa
it's gone tommy fam
fantastic again padres jump out to the
one-nothing lead
oppo what a way to start for san diego
well we've seen tommy pham many times
with that high pitch away
just shortening up squaring it up and it
will go
hydra deep left field off the bat of
fernando
at the wall it is gone fam
and fernando go back to back in the
first inning padres out to the
two-nothing lead
oh what a start from san diego this
lineup can be explosive at times
fernando tati's junior is good at
baseball
fly ball center field pavon smith
getting
ready makes the catch tagging at third
base is cronenworth
he will score easily in the padres take
a three-nothing lead
sac fly for will myers and that's going
to be it for corbin martin he will
retire only one batter
down three nothing responsible for three
padre base runners
carratini hits one of the air to center
haven smith out there waiting will make
the catch tagging at third is machado
he'll score easily and the padres take a
four nothing lead
oh barshow into third ahmed at second
down two outs for josh rojo
josh single to lead off the ball game
and rojas delivers it's in the gap
marshall will
score ahmed coming home as well joshua
rojas
cuts the lead in half he's two for two
and maters sends one down the line
that's a fair ball
rojas on the move he's coming around
third rojos is
in there josh rojos hustles all the way
from first base
and meters in at third and it's a 4-3
ball game
i could just hear those clicks on the
voting for fernando tatis junior
here's a drive to nick field back goes
peralta
at the walls gone nando's done it again
his second home run of the night and the
padres take a 5-3
lead fernando's 24th of the season
seventh career multi-home run game
high drive deep right field towards the
crown zone
gone padres went back to back in the
first
they go back to back in the second and
this time it's jake cutterworth
for the fourth straight game taking it
to the ground zone
ahmed singled his first time up one out
in the third
ahmed gets into one and drives it to
left that's going to get to the wall
david is home christian walker is home
varshaw stops at third nick in with a
big hit and once again it's a one-run
ball game
that's gonna be the end of the night for
chris paddock he goes
two and a third on a night in which the
padres score six runs
in the first two innings 63 coming into
this inning
it's now 6'5 and a grounder softly hit
towards chronoworth at second base
throws just in time
nicely done as ramirez gets out of any
further trouble it's 6-5
padre top of the order tommy fan hit a
lead off home run some three hours ago
when this game started
hey and getting hit is tommy fan
it was a fastball fam saying some stuff
marking out there empire walking fam
down to first base
andre's with four home runs in this game
and tommy famous of the opinion that
this was
intentional fernando drives on to center
field
david smith is back third home run of
the night for fernando
the trifecta
two run shot riley smith hits fam
and then fernando hits riley smith out
of the yard
8-5 san diego
on the ground to first base hosmer's got
it he'll flip the first off the glove of
diaz
and they got a couple runners at third
base right now
cronoworth running towards second and
the tag in time
they ran into and out it's gonna be
bases loaded
but varshall stopped at third base ahmed
kept coming towards third
and they end up getting him peter third
escobar at first two down to the
diamondback
sixth that is chopped towards short
tatis got a hurry
just in time for fernando threw a strike
to first base
able to get walker that ball was in the
air forever
finally comes down and then he throws
his strike to first
top of the order josh rojas who has been
on base
four times i think he went yeah he did
let's strike three and back-to-back
strikeouts for adams
seventh inning stretch last time it was
done
september of 17. never in
padres history hard hit through the left
side into left field a base hit
fourth hit of the night for fernando no
home run but he'll take it
listen into right base hit for hosmer
from third comes tatis
padres take a 9-5 lead
[Applause]
lying into right center field from
second comes hosmer
he'll score two second goes grisham with
an rbi double
padres take a 10-5 lead
line to center incoming is smith and
that's going to get it for a base hit
fam will score and the padres taking
11-5 lead
manny machado driving in a run
[Applause]
chopped up the middle here comes
fernando his throw
just in time ball game over
the padres have won eight straight games
and they take game one of the series